the challenge that many leaders face is
that we're analytical we think too
quickly about why something can't happen
or how to correct a problem as opposed
to twisting it and framing the brain
that this is an unexpected opportunity
what can I do with it
improvisation creates a set of learnings
a set of experiences that allows you to
fine tune and hone all of the necessary
skills needed to think on your feet and
simply react and adapt the cornerstone
of improvisation around the world is a
great two-word phrase called yes and yes
means that you accept everything that's
brought to you regardless of who brought
it to you regardless of what it is
regardless of what you think it means
based on who gave it to you accept it at
face value the an means you take this
idea and build directly upon it now
building directly upon it might seem
like it's always complimentary and
that's not always true you can build
upon something by taking it apart you
can build upon something by looking at
from a different angle so the yes
creates openness just the definition of
it it's affirmation its positive its
acceptance that creates a style of
thinking inside people and then the and
is your reaction to it the and is the
bridge to your thoughts the bridge to
your movement the bridge to how you
respond to others who are reacting to
this event in real time as well using
yes and as a tool you can actually
create environments that foster
creativity and foster talent leading of
course to innovation if there is a
difference between the two of those
creativity more of the process
innovation more of the product yes and
in dows people with fearlessness there's
not a mistake there's not a wrong way to
do something that's the editing process
and something that leaders have a
challenge with is editing too quickly
again we're analytical thinkers we're
critical thinkers we have to learn to
take that critical hat off and create an
environment in which it's okay for ideas
to fail it's okay for people to take
chances
once that area is created and
individuals are flourishing inside of it
you create a second area for editing
it's the difference between die
thinking and convergent thinking you
have to separate the two so you can
diverge your thoughts and come up with
this great collection of ideas and then
once you have this great collection of
ideas you focus on convergent thinking
you start separating the sand from the
gold and the good ideas from the bad
ideas and you start editing those out in
order to create this environment in
which people can come up with these
ideas and diverge their thinking you
have to cling to yes and so that you're
not editing too quickly